when all
hope seems lost
when heroes are needed more than
ever our fate is in there
pause a dog actually sir
i'm a puppy that's even worse you're in
shock so i'm not gonna take that
personally
this year another perfect rescue the
worldwide
phenomenon will be unleashed on the big
screen
paw patrol what's your emergency my name
is liberty we need your help
humdinger he's going to destroy
adventure city
come on pups adventure city's in trouble
[Music]
welcome to our new headquarters
this is so cool there's even a new and
improved pup treat dispenser
what it's a beautiful thing
no dog by order of the new mayor
he's more of a cat person ladies and
gentlemen and most importantly
influencers with over 10 000 followers
time
to light up the sky we've got to rescue
those people let's get to work
paw patrol are you
kidding me i got this get out of the way
move you got to know how to talk to
people
now go let's pick the tires and fight
some fires
this is what we do no city's too big
no pups too small
deploy
[Music]
yikes